mais moi je vous dirai que j'étais pas
gaulliste
oui mon opinion à moi il a fait la
guerre à l'abri
la ville de Chartres commémore
aujourd'hui sa libération comme de
nombreuses communes d'ailleurs
d'Eure-et-Loir par ville les figures de
cette période de l'histoire certains
résistants sont encore vivants comme
Simone seguin qui est entré dans la
clandestinité seulement à l'âge de 18
ans Simone Seguin dont vous connaissez
sans doute le visage Myriam métaoui et
Chloé Chauvry le rencontrer
cette photo a fait le tour du monde à 86
ans Simone se souvient parfaitement du
jour où ce fusil mitrailleur est entré
en sa possession
cultivateur qu'une chez moi dans la
peinture j'ai vu des Allemands
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire et
on les a désarmés fallait bien parce que
Monsieur que tu es avec moi quand tu es
mon mari enfin mon mari père de mes
enfants il parlait très bien l'allemand
et leur a dit qu'ils étaient prisonniers
qu'on leur ferait pas de mal mais qui
décide et c'est mitraillette et je l'ai
gardé
le célèbre cliché est pris au moment de
la libération de Chartres lors de la
venue du général de Gaulle alors le
général de Gaulle vous l'avez rencontré
j'ai rencontré
oui bah c'était la libération j'ai
rencontré à la Poste à
moi je vous dirai que j'étais pas voulu
mon opinion à moi il a fait la guerre à
l'abri
la jeune femme participe par la suite à
la libération de Paris en 1946 elle
reçoit la croix de guerre décorée par
Charles Tillon ministre de l'Armement
elle obtient le grade de sous-lieutenant
deux ans plus tôt quand les Allemands
viennent à chercher pour travailler elle
entre en clandestinité à 18 ans Simone
devient alors Nicole elle fait partie
des francs-tireurs et partisans elle
sillonnerait noir à bicyclette ce moyen
de transport une autre prise de guerre
tous les matins à La Poste de Chartres
il y a une jeune Allemande qui vient
chercher le courrier pour les Allemands
et me dit à telle heure billes elle est
vraiment quand elle sera rentrée vous
montez sur son vélo puis vous partez bon
chose non plus à accomplir c'était bon
67 ans plus tard Simone vie paisiblement
elle n'aspire qu'à une chose la paix
dans le monde elle regarde avec plus de
plaisir les photos de césarières
petits-enfants que celle de ses exploits
passés
[Musique]